-Thank you very much. Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
we are now officially
one week
into Joe Biden's presidency,
and for the first time
in a while,
a week actually felt
like a week.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, Biden's already been
in office for a week.
Time sure does fly
when you're not doom-scrolling
through Twitter till 4:00 a.m.
[ Laughter ]
Right now,
liquor stores are like,
"Where the hell
did everybody go? Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
In one week,
we've gone from insurrection
to cool and collected,
anarchy to no malarkey,
drinking bleach
to boring speech.
You know, it's been a ride.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'll take it.
And this is interesting --
even though Biden has only been
on the job for seven full days,
his initial approval rating is
higher than Trump's ever was.
-Ah.
-Whoo!
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure, by the end,
Trump's approval rating
was hovering around
the temperature that you have to
store the Pfizer vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Trump was like,
"Yeah.
But if you ask militia members
on the no-fly list,
my numbers
are through the roof."
[ Laughter ]
Well, Rudy Giuliani
is back in the headlines again
with more bad news.
YouTube just confirmed
that they're suspended --
they have suspended Rudy
from making money
off the ads
that play before his videos.
I didn't even know
Rudy was on YouTube.
[ Laughter ]
Let's take a look at what
he's doing over there.
-If you want a good cigar,
go to a good cigar shop.
-[ Laughing ] What?
-If you want the best,
go to Famous Smoke Shop.
American Hartford Gold
is the company you can trust
when it comes to buying gold.
Order Omega XL now
and get a second bottle free.
Earbuds from Raycon --
because they connect
my Bluetooth seamlessly
and you're
not having to untangle...
-What?!
-Wait.
...all these headphone wires.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Quick question.
-Is that real?
-Quick question --
who's buying earbuds 'cause
Rudy Giuliani recommends them?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was real?
-Yeah, it's real.
-For real?
-That's real.
Seriously,
what happened to Rudy?
I mean,
he's gone from QAnon to QVC.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Apparently,
Rudy's so desperate for cash,
he's gonna let Exxon start
drilling his head for oil.
-Ohh!
-Wow.
-Actually,
I don't know if it's true.
that's what I heard.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, some business news --
this is a good one here --
today, Kraft Heinz announced
its new pink, candy-flavored
macaroni and cheese
for Valentine's Day.
-Hm.
-Take a look at this.
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, God!
-Mmm. Candy-flavored pasta.
[ Italian accent ]
Just like Mama used to make.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Even
the Olive Garden looked at that
and said,
"Ah, that ain't right."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see it again?
-Mnh-mnh.
-No.
-I'm 99% sure that's what
custodians throw on the floor
after a kid barfs.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I -- I -- I -- I --
Can we just see it one qu--
I just got to look at it again.
Yeah.
-Ew.
-They even have a good name
for it -- Pepto-Bis-Mac.
[ Laughter ]
But this is funny --
so, later this year,
the Postal Service
is going to release
a new series of
"Star Wars" stamps.
I never thought I'd have to lick
C-3PO to pay my cable bill,
but here we are.
[ Laughter ]
When he saw the news,
Jimmy Carter was like,
"I've never been on a stamp,
but by all means,
let's give one to R2-D2."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is exciting --
Six Flags Great Adventure
in New Jersey
just finished the track
for its 130-foot-high
Jersey Devil Coaster.
And when it opens,
it'll be the world's tallest,
fastest, and longest
single-rail coaster.
Of course,
since it's New Jersey,
your hair's got to be
this tall to ride.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
It's nice that
they added a new roller coaster.
The other roller coasters
in that park are so old,
they still have ashtrays.
[ Laughter ]
"[Exhales sharply]
Does this thing go upside down?"
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that,
'cause of the pandemic,
New Yorkers can now order
scratch-off tickets online
and have them delivered
right to their house.
I'm not --
I'm not sure I love this idea.
One of my favorite
New York traditions
was waiting in line
with my lunch
while the guy ahead of me took
15 minutes to pick out tickets.
"Give me the three Lucky 7's.
I'll do, uh, two Birthday Bucks.
I want the, uh,
BOGGLE Cashword
and, uhhh...
five Tic Tac Snows."
[ Laughter ]
"Well, you touched
the sixth one.
Give me six of them.
Why not?"
[ Laughter ]
"Go with sixes --
that's the secret.
These are scratch-offs.
Every sixth one is a winner."
[ Laughter ]
"But that's the fourth one,
so give me two more.
Give me eight tickets.
And that starts the six again."
[ Laughter ]
What?
And finally,
some news from overseas --
China has rolled out
an anal swab coronavirus test...
-Ohh, ohh, come on.
[ Laughter ]
-...saying it's more accurate
than the throat method.
It's more accurate,
but it's still being called
the number-two test.
-Ah!
[ Drums play ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And for even more accuracy,
they do a nasal swab
and an anal swab
until they touch in the middle.
-No! Aah!